all right as you can see we're waiting
the president joining us now first South
Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham all
right senator over the weekend they were
going to cap to 16,500 the number of
people ice can detain we hear now there
might be a breakthrough I don't trust it
I don't believe it what do you know I
know the president will never sign a
bill that caps bed space probe island
offenders because that's crazy
this dangerous annual incentivize more
illegal immigration the party the
Democratic Party doesn't want to build a
wall and apparently if you come in in
the country legally and we catch you
they don't want to hold you so other
than that they're in a good spot on
border security okay you know what this
break quote breakthrough is no I don't
but I know what cannot be in it you
cannot have a cap on bed space this is
interior detention when we catch you
inside the country
there's bed spaces for people caught at
the border but if we catch you inside
the country like in New York the ms-13
gangs this is where we catch most of the
criminals they get through the border
they they get themselves you know
integrated into the country we've been
deporting thousands of gang members this
would deny us the bed space to hold them
until they're deported it is a dangerous
concept the president will not agree to
it to get more wal money to limit bed
space is a bad dangerous deal alright
let's talk about us 284 which I was
discussing earlier language is clear I
read the statute you just pointed out to
me by Senator Lee your colleague Mike
Lee of Utah the language that I put up
on the screen is crystal clear the
president has the right to do this right
yeah I mean basically we've allocated
money to deal with drug corridors but
there's also language in the
appropriations bill where you can move
around four billion dollars inside the
Department of Defense in the discretion
of the secretary and the president so
there's well over four billion dollars
available to the president under current
law in addition to what the Congress
will give him in this deal so I would
assume they would take the money in the
deal it won't be enough it would be well
short of five seven
and do what we talked about to make up
the difference between the appropriate
amount in the 5/7